nicht nur ihr die klicks um zuschauer
vermuten dass es sich beim
interstellaren objekt das durch unser
sonnensystem gerast ist um ein fremdes
raumschiff um ein alien raumschiff
handelt ein forschungsteam des
breakthrough listen projektes will heute
das weltgrößte bewegliche teleskop auf
das interstellare objekt ausrichten um
es abzuhören
das team um den astronomie professor
wille von der harvard university rechnet
sich tatsächlich chancen aus von dort
signale zu empfangen alle infos dazu
jetzt bei klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
es ist wirklich frappierend zum ersten
mal wurde ein objekt beobachtet dass aus
dem interstellaren raum gekommen ist und
durch unser sonnensystem geflogen ist
und dabei vollführt es noch ein
perfektes ringen bei manöver um unsere
sonne
so wie wir menschen es mit satelliten um
planeten in unserem sonnensystem machen
und es hat noch eine ganz besondere und
tatsächlich seltsame form die eines
spiels oder eben eines raumschiffes
zitat dieses ding ist sehr merkwürdig
dass sagt carole white von der
universität von hawaii
das team der forscherin hat das objekt
aufgrund von beobachtungsdaten näher
beschrieben und es wirklich ziemlich
spooky das team hat herausgefunden dass
das objekt alle 7,3 stunden um seine
eigene achse rotiert und dabei immer
heller und wieder dunkler wird um das
zehnfache zitat diese ungewöhnlich
starker helligkeit änderung deutet
darauf hin dass das objekt sehr lang
gezogen sein muss etwa zehnmal so lang
wie breit mit einer komplexen gebundenen
form erklärt die forscherin mit auch
extrem seltsam das objekt hat eine farbe
es ist rot und auch ihr habt vermutet
dass es ein raumschiff ist rap bekamen
98 likes für diese einschätzung der lage
zitat ich denke immer noch dass es ein
raumschiff ist was vom galaxie zu
galaxie fliegt und sich die gravitation
vom planeten zunutze macht um
angetrieben zu werden ein zwingen bei
manöver vermutet rap auch und das ist
offenbar auch eine ansicht die
astronomie teams teilen heute soll das
green bank teleskop im us staat virginia
zehn stunden lang auf vier verschiedenen
funkübertragung bändern nach
radiosignalen des objektes suchen das
objekt ist inzwischen doppelt so weit
von der erde entfernt wie die sonne es
ist also noch relativ nah und es ist
relativ einfach sechs schwache signale
zu empfangen dort signale zu finden
wären für das forschungsteam nicht
komplett ausgeschlossen am zweiten
september tauchte das interstellare
objekt ja senkrecht zudem umlaufbahnen
der planeten in unserem sonnensystem
zwischen sonne und merkur bayern ein
die gravitation der sonder lenkte das
objekt dann unterhalb der sonne in
richtung erde um wo es unterhalb der
erdumlaufbahn am 14 oktober an der erde
vorbei führung inzwischen ist das objekt
durch die umlenkung der sonne wieder
über die planeten hinaus geschossen
worden
dabei wurde das objekt erst entdeckt als
es schon an der erde vorbeigeflogen war
am 18 oktober 2000
17 führte das 1,8 meter teleskop an
stars 1 auf der hawaii-insel maui das
objekt auf und dann ergaben die
berechnungen des objektes sehr schnell
dass es nicht von dieser welt war nicht
von einem anderen planeten im
sonnensystem und überhaupt nicht aus
unserem sonnensystem
es gab sogar noch überhaupt keine
kategorie für das objekt und weil es
irrtümlich für einen asteroiden gehalten
wurde bekam es erstmals die falsche
bezeichnung a 2000 17 uhr 1 inzwischen
hat die internationale astronomische
union eine neue kategorie für
interstellare objekte eingeführt ist
jetzt die bezeichnet ist also jetzt 1
2017 u1 und hat auch einen
hawaiianischen namen bekommen humor wenn
es nicht so unglaublich unwahrscheinlich
wäre könnte man es eben für ein
raumschiff alten so extrem seltsam wie
es aussieht hinzukommt zitat außerdem
konnten wir bestätigen dass es
vollständig inaktiv ist weil wir in
seiner direkten umgebung nicht den
geringsten hinweis auf staub finden
konnten berichtete mitch und das
forschungsteam vermutet deshalb dass das
fremde objekt aus gestein oder eben eine
mix mit hohen metallanteil besteht
das würde für ein raumschiff sprechen
und anders als zunächst vermutet hatte
es nicht einen durchmesser von 160
metern sondern war sogar 400 meter lang
es ist ein wirklich wirklich seltsam als
objekt also eben rund genug ist jetzt zu
untersuchen allerdings schätzt das
forschungsteam die chancen als gering
ein tatsächlich signale von dem objekt
zu empfang eine wahrscheinlichkeit gibt
es zwar aber sie ist gering aber auch
wenn keine signale von humor gesendet
werden ist diese attraktion heute nicht
vergeblich das astronomie team erhofft
sich auch weitere daten die aufschluss
über die zusammensetzung des objektes
geben ist es eher ja wieso ein asteroid
aus stein oder eine art komet mit eis
und staub ja wenn ihr also kein video
zum aktuellen stand verpassen wollt dann
drückt mir hier ein abo aufsaugen
vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch
über die neuesten videos informiert hier
geht es weiter und dafür einfach
draufklicken mit dem ersten video zur
entdeckung des objektes sensation
interstellare objekt rast durchs
sonnensystem mit weiteren infos und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran